pas de traîneau pour le père noël cette
année à maurepas
mais des palettes remplie de cadeaux
tout de même le secours populaire il
enseigne picwic ont uni leurs forces ce
week-end pour gâter des enfants
défavorisés les enfants défavorisés ont
besoin de jouer neuf
ils ont droit comme tous les enfants du
monde avoir déjoué de bonne qualité et
on remercie énormément tous les clients
du magasin qui qui nous ont aidés dans
cette démarche
on vend du jouet et je crois qu'on vend
un peu de rêve aussi et que là on est
complètement dans la lignée de ce que 2
de notre métier à la base
tout le monde n'a pas forcément les
l'argent la facilité pouvoir s'acheter
des jouets si nous on peut aider à ce
niveau là on en est ravi des dvd des
poupées déluge ou encore des toupies
tous les cadeaux sont les bienvenus
l'équipe du secours populaire compte sur
la solidarité et la générosité des
acheteurs les chansons nouvelles
beaucoup donnent de très beaux jouets et
on est toujours étonné la quantité de
vous et on a fait 50 5 à 10 en deux
jours ce qui est une belle performance
l'objectif offrir un peu de magie à une
cinquantaine d'enfants pour noël une
démarche que l'enseigne renouvelle leur
défaite depuis trois ans on a remis 1
5100 euros de jouer ce qui représentait
à peu près 700 pièces de jouer pas mal
de jeux vidéo aussi et beaucoup de
mesures création le père noël passera
avec un peu d'avancé les cadeaux
récoltés lors de ce week end seront
remis aux enfants le 21 décembre